So to do that, we have to think about
pictures as of not just a collection
of pixels, but actually as a graph.
And what I mean by
a graph is shown here.
So, in the graph we have a,
a node for every pixel, okay?
And between every pair of
pixels is a link, okay?
Just as in any other graph,
those are the edges of our graph, right?
And on each edge, there's what's
referred to as an affinity weight, or
just a weight, and
here that's written as wpq, all right?
And the idea is that I'm
going to need an edge for
any weight that is nonzero, okay?
And the weight is going to measure
the similarity between two pixels.
And the two, and the similarity will be
essentially inversely proportional to
the difference.
So that just means that the,
the more different they are,
the less similar they are.
And another way of saying it is
if the difference is too big,
I'm going to say the similarity is zero.
So those edges go away.
So I'm going to build a,
a weight matrix, using this affinity.
So I, a standard affinity, for
example, might be that I'm just
going to use a Gaussian, right?
Where I say the,
the affinity between two pixels, i and
j, is just this exponentiation,
as a function,
just as exponentiation as
a function of the distance.
So of course, there is a parameter here.
And here, you can see the change in
affinity depending upon what that
parameter is you get
these different curves.
And essentially if you use a very small
sigma this thing goes, grows quickly.
So in which case, only nearby pixels
get any reasonable affinity at all.
Whereas if you have a large sigma,
you can connect,
you can have strong infinities in
between points that are somewhat far
away, far away in your distance space.
So if your distance includes just color,
then it would be that.
But typically, our distance is also
going to include actual distance.